JANE MCGONIGAL:
Um, and now I think
we're going to do some Q&A.
AUDIENCE: Um, so from
a teaching perspective,
how come kids who
are gamers don't
seem to apply the sort
of being OK with failure,
and exploring the system, and
all of that in the classroom
setting?
And how can I make them do that?
JANE MCGONIGAL: Yeah.
I mean, there are a
couple of reasons.
I mean, in classroom
environments,
there tend to be more
consequences for failure,
right?
I mean, even at
the younger levels,
if you don't do
well on something,
you will be perceived as
not being good at that.
That could affect what
group you're put in.
As you get older
and you fail a test,
it counts towards your grades.
You don't get to retake it.
I know there are a lot of
schools that are experimenting
with trying to create
structures for failing that more
closely resemble games.
So schools where you can
take a test as many times
as you want, the same way
you would play a level
as many times as you want,
to focus on mastery rather
than performance anxiety.
There's a chapter-- Chapter
4 in the book talks about,
though specifically, why
do only some people seem
to bring the gameful
mindset to everyday life?
And at least 41%
of gamers do not
bring this to everyday life.
And it has to do with
whether you view games
as being escapist or whether
you view them as being
a part of your real life.
So we have this bias.
We talk about games
as being escapist,
and you leave reality, and it
helps you forget, you know,
everyday life.
And when people
are playing games,
we tell them they're
wasting time, right?
People who feel that
way tend to play games
more when their life gets more
stressful, because they see it
as this kind of
coping mechanism,
the same way some
people drink more
when their life gets stressful,
or they eat junk food,
or they just-- and so then
their problems get bigger.
And so then they have to
play games more 'cause
they're more stressed out now.
And it creates this
downward spiral,
and that's actually the
number one predictor of, like,
who becomes addicted
to games are people
who see games as escapist.
People who benefit and
sort of the way out of that
seems to be people who
focus when they play games
on how they're getting better.
So I play this game,
I'm getting better
at spatial intelligence, or
teamwork, or coordination,
or designing, or creativity,
or whatever it is.
So the really practical
answer to that question
is to talk to kids about
the games they play and say,
what do you have to be good
at to be good at this game?
Or to model back to them.
Wow, it took you four
days to finish that level?
That sounds really hard.
You must be somebody who,
when you have a goal,
you don't give up until
you really succeed.
And start to help kids see
that there are real character
strengths that are
part of who they are,
not just when they're
playing games.
They don't have to escape
reality to have those feelings
or have those strengths.
So it's like a whole
chapter about how
you do that in Chapter 4.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Thank you.
JANE MCGONIGAL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, now
I have the mic.
I've been talking about
"SuperBetter" a lot
with a friend,
because there was just
an article in the last
"Psychology Today" about it.
And we thought it was cool, and
we had this whole discussion
about what are our powerups
and what are our bad guys.
And that was cool.
So my question is
actually a question
from my friend, who
says, please ask, I'm
curious as to how effectively
people use "SuperBetter"
to deal with issues I
might be concerned about,
like procrastination
and mild anxiety,
rather than deeply debilitating
depression, et cetera.
JANE MCGONIGAL: Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK.
So I'm going to give it
to you straight here.
This method seems to work better
and better the more difficult
your challenge is.
So we crunched the numbers, and
people who signed up to, like,
I want to lose 10 pounds,
I want to run my first 5K,
I don't know, I'm just bored
with my life, I want to change,
those people do not
register a lot of benefits.
There's measurement tools
inside the system where
we look at changes in
things like courage,
and optimism, and
things like that.
Those people don't
register as many changes.
Whereas people who come
with big problems, you
know-- I just lost
a family member,
I've been diagnosed
with something,
I have always
suffered with anxiety,
they register the
biggest changes.
I think that's important.
And there are lots of reasons
that would make sense why.
I mentioned the idea of
post-traumatic growth earlier.
As I explained in the book,
the "SuperBetter" method,
at its heart, what
it seems to do
is promote
post-traumatic growth.
In order to have
post-traumatic growth,
you have to have some kind of
serious challenge or trauma.
Now, there is a version
of post-traumatic growth
that does not require trauma.
It's called
post-ecstatic growth.
So I also talk about
that in the book.
But it still requires
you to do something
that is extremely difficult--
so running a marathon, not
a 5K, a marathon.
Trying to maybe write your
first book, starting a company,
becoming a parent
for the first time.
So positive things,
but that will really
force you to dig
deep and cultivate
that new form of strength.
So the short version
is it might help,
but it will make a
bigger difference
in the lives of
people who are really
struggling with something.
So one suggestion is,
put it on your phone now
and hopefully you don't need it.
But maybe someday it
will help you more.
AUDIENCE: I've
tried to use games
as a way of developing
particular cognitive styles,
and I've often found
I'll start playing
a game with the intent of
I'm going to be practicing
some cognitive skill or other.
And then I find an
hour has passed,
and I notice I slipped
totally into complacency,
and I wasn't practicing
that cognitive style.
I wasn't trying the new strategy
that I had intended to try.
How do I maintain
the focus required
when playing games to make sure
that I actually do use them
as that sort of practice, rather
than idly passing the time?
JANE MCGONIGAL: Well,
that's really interesting.
Because on one hand,
I mean, I would
think, from what I've seen,
that idly passing the time
is actually totally fine.
I mean, that it will
do the same thing.
You don't have to adopt a
particular style of gameplay
or strategy.
So we talked about playing
a game you've never
played before will make
that mindset happen faster
than playing a game
you've played 100 times.
So maybe it'd be more
a matter of making sure
that you're exposing
yourself to different games,
different genres of games.
You know, if you've never
played a certain genre,
to try to expand your competency
with different kinds of games.
I would think that aspect of
making sure that you're always
requiring yourself to be
learning and improving
is probably the most
important aspect of it.
But other than that, there's
not a particular, you know.
Just make sure that it's
really challenging for you,
and challenge yourself to
learn different games is just
a really good way to do that.
Cool.
What else?
You guys pick.
AUDIENCE: Um, so
you said we should
ask this question earlier.
What can go wrong with violent
video games that doesn't--
JANE MCGONIGAL:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK.
So all of the stuff
they report in the media
is hype and not true
except for if you
spend most of your
time playing violent,
aggressive-themed games--
we'll use "Call of Duty"
as an example--
against people you
don't know online-- not in
the same space-- the one
negative side effect of
that is that it boosts
your testosterone in a
way that does not happen
in other gameplay contexts.
It doesn't happen if you
are playing against people
you know in real life.
So we don't have to
be in the same room.
But if I know I'm playing
you and we're cool,
I'm not going to get this
sort of testosterone-jack.
There's a lot of research behind
it that I explain in the book.
But for now, we'll
just say you can get,
basically,
testosterone poisoning,
is how one researcher
describes it,
where after you're done
playing, for hours afterwards
can make you just more
hostile in your interaction
with other people,
more aggressive, less
compassion and empathy,
'cause you're really
jacked up on testosterone, which
just has that effect on people.
So, you know, that's why
some game communities
may have a reputation
for the kind of people
that become kind of jerks.
So I recommend that you spend
less than half your time
doing that.
If you're going to play
a lot of these games,
make sure you're spending a
significant amount of time
playing them with people you
know, that you have to continue
to have relationships
with, because that's
what dampens the testosterone.
However, I'm a very
open-minded person.
I think people should use games
to benefit themselves however
they want.
There may be people who want
to jack up some testosterone.
I'm going into a
contract negotiation,
and I do want to be aggressive.
Or you may want that.
So I am not to judge.
There may be benefits to it as
well, but that is the genre.
So thanks for
coming back to that.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
if you've investigated
a relationship between your
work on PTSD and other work,
like van der Kolk's "The
Body Keeps the Score,"
ideas of trauma being stored
somatically, physically.
JANE MCGONIGAL: No, I'm
not familiar with that,
but the name is very evocative.
"Your Body Keeps the Score"?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that was a new book,
"The Body Keeps the Score."
JANE MCGONIGAL: I'm going to buy
that. [LAUGHING] That's great.
Thank you for that.
AUDIENCE: So I was kind of
curious about the reference
to motor neurons,
knowing some of that.
It's pretty controversial,
A. And it only
applies to sort of where
motor activity's involved.
I'm kind of curious, not knowing
anything about the gaming
world, I'm people-watching
these videos screens
of other people playing.
How much of that is, like,
actual, physical activity
that their motor
neurons can actually
relate to versus
intellectual, like if it's
Scrabble or some boring thing?
I can look at golf, and
I'm always turned off.
JANE MCGONIGAL: Yeah.
I mean, I would contest
the idea that it's
just-- I know there are
discussions now going on
about this sort
of-- what is that?
The hype cycle, the hype chart?
It went into the trough
of disillusionment.
But you do absolutely still see
mirror neurons even in things,
you know, conversations.
If we're close friends
and you're telling me
about your day, we do see that
my brain will, as you tell me
your story, start to
mirror the experience is
if it happened to me.
And I don't know that
that necessarily-- I mean,
you see the same kind
of emotional activation.
I feel like there's a
sufficient body of literature
that there is a general
processing of experience that
can be mirrored.
That's where I come down on it.
It's just sort of the--
people are arguing about it.
You know, there is a
strong physical component,
I mean, in the same way that
speed typing has a component.
You have to be able
to input decisions
and execute decisions very
quickly through the interface.
It could be possible
to be part of.
I mean, you think about
the piano example.
I mean, that is
probably similar,
playing the piano, and the
controls of a video game.
You still have to be
mirroring the musicality.
I mean, you have to
have the understanding
of the musicality, and not just
the execution of the interface.
But--
So we have time for
one more, maybe.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
JANE MCGONIGAL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So
sometimes when you're
achieving a goal
in a video game,
it feels really frustrating.
So is there a value, positive
or negative, in the frustration,
or is there only a value
in achieving the goal?
JANE MCGONIGAL: Oh, no.
No, no, no.
Most of the value is
in the frustration.
I mean, it is.
The value is in staying
motivated and optimistic while
being frustrated.
So when we were
looking at that--
what is the mindset
of a super-powered,
hopeful, individual?
That is somebody who's highly
motivated, and optimistic,
and able to learn, and try,
and be flexible, and try
different strategies, so that
in the face of frustration,
they will continue to
engage with the obstacle.
It's why I like to
play games myself
that are very challenging.
I love it when I have to try
a level 100 times before I
get past it.
That's where a lot of
the resilience that
seems to be one of the most
essential-- what do games
make us good at?
Being resilient in the face
of that kind of frustration.
So yeah.
Don't play games that you're
good at and always winning.
That's just positive emotion.
But the actual
positive psychology,
the strengths will come
out of playing games
that you are bad at, which is
why we played a game that you
guys would-- you guys,
you're surprisingly
good at massive and
multi-player Scrabble, though.
It was good.
Good.
Well, good to meet you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]